>>Jason Darnell: Somewhere down
the line learning became not fun.
I think somehow kids started
coming to school and saying,
"I'm not gonna have fun today.
I'm going to school."
And the reward of Historia, it's fun.
>>Rick Brennan: Historia
is game-based learning.
It is a way to take a traditional
subject, like social studies,
but to teach it through
experience and interactivity.
>>Student: Historia is using history
and learning it through game play
and you get to experience
it as your own country.
>>Rick Brennan: All
right, here we go...
>>Twenty-eight.
Oh, my god!
[ cheers ]
>>Jennifer Pung: Sixth
graders, when they come
into school it's their first
time in a big building.
There's kids coming from all
different schools so they're not
from the same elementary school.
So a sixth grade mind is very social.
They're gonna talk to
each other at their table
and not necessarily be listening.
So when Historia comes around it's
definitely challenging the first few
weeks while you're setting it
up, because they are confused.
They don't know exactly what
they're supposed to be doing,
but then once it gets started all
those things kind of go to the side.
I still hear them talking
to their friends,
but the conversation switches
from the latest movie into
"Well, what points did you get?
How did you do?"
>>Student: The best part
of Historia, I think,
is being able to create
your own history,
because not only do you learn
about other countries during
that time period, you get to
learn about what has happened
and what can happen to you.
>>Student: Have you
ever heard of "eye
for an eye" and "tooth for a tooth"?
That comes from Hammurabi's Code.
>>Student: If I have a teacher
stand in front of me talking,
it's very hard for me to remember
'cause I get bored, distracted.
With Historia it's no
place to get distracted.
You working the whole time and
making decisions as a group.
>>Jason Darnell: So what are you
finding is the most important pillar
that allows you to kind
of build the other ones?
>>Maybe education.
>>Education and government.
>>Jason Darnell: Interesting.
>>It's important that
students feel success,
'cause if they don't feel
successful they'll give up.
And at the beginning when we first
made the game, it was too hard.
And the students would-- you would
have a group that was doing so poorly
that by the second half of the year,
you'd see them a little detached,
because they'd say,
"What's the point?"
You know, "I've done the best I can
and now we're still not successful.
I don't have time for this."
You know? So Rick and
I tried to build
in ways students could be successful
each week, or every other week,
to where it's gonna get them
to keep on coming back to it.
>>Student: You do learn a lot because
you have to research everything
and you have to learn what to do
and how to make right decisions
and you learn how to be a
government and learn how
to interact with other people.
>>Rick Brennan: Who's
the monarch here?
>>Me.
>>Rick Brennan: Carson.
Okay. So what's the bet gonna be?
>>Seven.
Oh, wait. Eight, eight.
Yeah.
>>Eight.
>>Rick Brennan: It's eight.
Okay, you all think
that's a good bet?
>>Mm-hm.
>>Jared likes ten.
>>Rick Brennan: You like ten?
>>Carson: Four hundred forty-five.
>>But then we
remembered slave revolt,
so I'm like, "Let's do eight."
>>Rick Brennan: Okay, okay.
We'll see how it turns.
Good.
>>If I look at my job as everything
you need to know is in my brain
and I am your source of information,
I feel like I'm sending
the wrong message,
which is "Somebody
else knows the answer".
>>Jason Darnell: With Historia, the
teacher is just there to facilitate.
You're there to guide
the learning instead
of being the center for learning.
You're there to help kids
learn how to research better.
You're there to help kids compromise.
You're there to help kids
learn to make better decisions
and that's how learning should be.
>>Rick Brennan: In my experience,
thirteen years of teaching,
this is best teaching practice.
When I didn't teach this way, I would
still have ten percent of my class
who I would struggle to get to pay
attention even though I did projects
and games and mixed it up
in debate and all that.
I tried to make the class
the best I could make it.
Even when I did that and worked
very hard at it, took it seriously,
ten percent of my class
maybe wouldn't pay attention.
I don't have that problem now.
>>Jason Darnell: When I
started teaching my mantra was
"I am not scared to fail."
Failing is how you learn,
making mistakes is how you get more
knowledgeable and become better.
And so I would try anything in
my classroom to make a connection
with my students, to make
my class more engaging.